welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my new Star Wars rise of
Skywalker video for the Mandalorian in
baby Yoda I got a lot of questions about
them during my rise of Skywalker videos
so we'll break it down if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos we're doing a
merch giveaway because they finally have
baby Yoda merch on sale all you have to
do to enter that is be a subscriber and
leave your favorite moment from the
Mandalorian tour rise of Skywalker on
the video obviously careful for spoilers
from Star Wars the rise of Skywalker as
well as the Mandalorian series you
really have to know what's going on with
baby Yoda during the events of that
series in what they're trying to set up
with that plot to understand what's
going on later in the timeline because
if you're not sure what's happening and
when it's happening in the timeline the
Mandalorian series takes place five
years after Return of the Jedi the
events of the new trilogy start about
thirty years after Return of the Jedi so
you have to assume it baby Yoda is
around fifty years old as they said
during season one of the Mandalorian he
be between 75 and 78 around the time
brides of Skywalker is happening the
Mandalorian is quite a bit younger than
baby Yoda though because he was around 7
or 8 during the events of the Clone Wars
because you see the giant separatist
battle droids come and end his parents
so during the events of the new trilogy
the Mandalorian would be in his late 60s
early 70s just for the sake of
comparison though Han Solo is about 66
during the events of force awakens he
looks way older than that just because
he's got a lot of city miles on him and
Harrison Ford is 73 when they're filming
that if they didn't use any of Marvel's
special D aging technology that they do
in the Marvel movies making the older
actors look quite a bit younger they did
it for Carrie Fisher just a little bit
but Luke Skywalker is about 53 54 during
the events of last Jedi he also looks a
lot older because in real life Mark
Hamill was 66 when they filmed that and
they also didn't use any special D aging
technology for him so even though the
Mandalorian himself underneath that
helmet Pedro Pascal's character would be
pretty old he wouldn't be extremely old
baby Yoda has already shown us he's
super powerful he's been able to force
choke people exhibiting some sith powers
has been able to levitate the mud horn
he's been able to force heal people
which is also a power that we saw Rey
use for the first time during rise of
Skywalker which previously used
be like a god tier Legends ability so
baby Oda is this powerful why wouldn't
he be around at the age of 75 quite a
bit older quite a bit more powerful and
physically just have grown a little bit
more so he's actually physically larger
in size typical humanoid children that
you see during the prequels when Yoda is
training all those younglings are
between the ages of 7 and 8 when they
start training so if he Otis Reis
matures at about the same rate that
humans do comparatively by the time he's
70 75 almost 80 years old he would
definitely be ready to start formal Jedi
training and because members of Yoda's
race are always born so innately
powerful in the force and so force
sensitive he would probably be as
powerful if not way more powerful than
Anakin Skywalker was around the time of
Attack of the Clones
after he'd had a little bit of Jedi
training under him some of the abilities
we've seen baby Yoda use our abilities
that you've only seen previously from
adult Jedi and Sith so you have to
assume that he's way more advanced way
more powerful than any of the Jedi
you've seen before we don't hear any
mention of him during rise of Skywalker
Emperor Palpatine doesn't talk about
trying to track down any of the other
force sensitive people around the galaxy
he's only focused on tricking Rey into
killing him in hatred so that she will
fully become Sith and his force spirit
can enter her body and hopefully I think
the idea is that he wants to take over
her body and that he could rule the
galaxy through her form but there's this
whole subplot on the Mandalorian right
now about the Empire the remnants of the
Empire through Moff Gideon's character
and all the territory that he controls
and troops using baby Yoda to
reestablish Imperial dominance in the
wake of the fall of the Empire returned
the Jedi so there's a lot of missing
timeline if they knew about him then and
he's such this topic of interest for the
former Empire then why isn't the first
order looking for him why isn't Emperor
Palpatine talking about him we're really
still just in season one of the
Mandalorian series so we're only just
learning about the other remnants of the
Empire we just met moth Gideon so we
don't know who else is working with him
besides Doctor Pershing in the cloning facility on Kamino
there was this whole subplot during rise
of Skywalker about Emperor Palpatine
saying that he'd been cloning Snoke this
whole time so using techniques he's
already been doing a measure of what it
seems like Moff Gideon is trying to do
with baby Yoda create a new army of
force-sensitive clones or at least use
some of his DNA to
humanoid clones that are then force
sensitive and lived way longer in her
way more powerful and easily
controllable but if the Mandalorian runs
four or five seasons obviously this is
just the beginning of what their plans
for baby Yoda are but I like to think
the Star Wars at least in the end tries
to be as optimistic as possible even
though they kind of drag some people
through the mud on the way there
George Lucas is so utterly protective of
the way new Star Wars stories used the
Yoda character in Yoda's race that I
don't think he would allow Dave Filoni
his surrogate son in Jon Favreau to
create a new member of his race only to
then kill him off really quickly the
whole concept of his race is that they
represent one of the truest connections
to the force on a biological and
spiritual level the whole metaphor being
that the smallest tiniest creatures are
somehow the most innately powerful so
for the sake of argument let us assume
that baby Yoda is still alive in a well
during the events of the new trilogy
he's probably just still in the Outer
Rim territories living with the
Mandalorian who is much older now who
since the events of season one has
officially become his surrogate father
in a more official capacity and they
also have slowly been working to restore
the Mandalorian people along with the
other people in the Mandalorian clan in
addition to eventually restoring Yoda's
race but those are really really long
term goals
remember how rare it is for members of
Yoda's race to be born in the galaxy at
any given time there's really only one
or two like yeah ttle is the only other
one that we see during the prequels and
she actually left after Phantom Menace I
think the best explanation for why baby
Yoda isn't around during the events of
the new trilogy or during rise of
Skywalker at all why he's never
mentioned by any of the characters is
mostly that he's here on the other side
of the galaxy in the Outer Rim like
remember we saw them go to Tatooine
Tatooine is on the exact opposite side
of the galaxy from where Palpatine is on
Exogol in the Unknown Regions we don't
know exactly where that planet is we
just noticed in the unknown regions and
that's this part of space way up here
the reason why the first-order probably
isn't trying to hunt him down or Emperor
Palpatine isn't trying to find baby Yoda
is probably because the only people who
knew of his existence during the events
of the Mandalorian series were Moff
Gideon's men in his inner circle and
since then they've all either been
destroyed off by the Mandalorian trying to
protect baby Yoda or at some point
during the Mandalorian series they switch sides and tried to
help him like Doctor Pershing seems like
he's going to eventually help them in
through their actions they're probably
able to either erase all records baby
Yoda at least all Imperial records or
silence all the people that would
eventually seek to do him harm so the
for the most part he literally and
metaphorically flies under the radar as
he continues to grow up living with the
Mandalorian under his protection you
also have to assume that they were
creating the series in thinking about
creating the character while they were
actually filming and working on rise of
Skywalker so it was probably too late in
the game to actually stuff him in and
because they spent so much time trying
to keep a lid on the secret of baby Yoda
being introduced in the Mandalorian
series there's no merchandise they
didn't put him in any of the marketing
so they probably wanted to keep him out
of rise of Skywalker on purpose just to
help keep the secret but I think the
idea is presumably after the events of
the rise of Skywalker ending scene where
Rey berries Luke and Leia's lightsabers
and then names herself a Skywalker she
sets out on the task of finding other
force sensitive beings around the galaxy
and creating a new Jedi Temple with the
help of the Jedi Tech's which she's kept
Finn is a really good example of a new
force sensitive person now confirmed by
the filmmakers and by John boyega
himself he would probably wind up being
one of her first Padawans and no idea
where broom boy was when this was all
happening or if it even noticed that he
was force sensitive when they were on
canto bite but the whole idea of the new
trilogy is that there are all these
force sensitive people out there all
over the place and it's just on rate to
spend the rest of her life finding them
and rebuilding the Jedi Order and
eventually at some point baby Yoda would
cross paths with her they would sense
each other through the force across the
galaxy and keep in mind even if he
waited a couple years after the events
of rise of Skywalker he would be
rounding out aged 80 by the time that
happened eventually he would have to
find someone else to help take care of
baby Yoda if he was not already able to
take care of himself
so if you're still a little confused
about what's going on there is no baby
Yoda or a Mandalorian during rise of
Skywalker anywhere there is a minor
easter egg in the background of this
giant fleet when all the ships come to
fight on x ago you see all these
different types of ships in the
background there is a ship right here
that looks like the same configuration
as the Mandalorians razor crest ship I
think it's safer to assume that babe
Yoda will eventually show up in the
movies set after the events of rise of
Skywalker everyone post your theories in
the comments below
where is baby Yoda hiding out during the
events of the new trilogy the
Mandalorian Episode 8 finale is going to be
on Friday of course I'll post my video
for that I'll be doing more Mandalorian
bonus videos for season 2 and all that
stuff because they are about halfway
done filming season 2 right now
congratulations Alex Ramirez you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Star
Wars video please email me on the about
page of my channel so I can get your
details everyone click here for my brand new
Mandalorian episode 7 video and click
here for my Star Wars rise of Skywalker
top 20 video thank you so much for
watching happy holidays Merry Christmas
everyone I'll see you guys tonight!